one of the most important principles for
choosing a lover sensibly is not to feel
in any hurry to make a choice being
satisfied with being single is a
precondition of satisfactory coupledom
we cannot choose wisely when remaining
single feels unbearable we have to be
utterly at peace with the prospect of
many years of solitude in order to have
any chance of forming a good
relationship or will love no longer
being single rather more that we love
the partner who's spared us being so
unfortunately after a certain age
society makes singlehood feel
dangerously unpleasant communal life
starts to wither people in couples are
too threatened by the independence of
the single to invite them around very
often in case they're reminded of
something they might have missed
friendship and sex are despite all the
gadgets still remarkably hard to come by
no wonder if when someone slightly
decent but not quite so comes along we
cling to them to our eventual enormous
cost when sex was only available within
marriage people recognized that this
would lead some people to marry for the
wrong reasons to obtain something that
was artificially restricted in society
as a whole sexual liberation was
intended to allow people to have a
clearer head when choosing who they
really wanted to be with but this
process remains only half-finished
only when we can make sure that being
single is as potentially as secure warm
and fulfilling as being in a couple well
we know that people are choosing to pair
up for the right reasons it's time to
liberate companionship from the shackles
of coupledom and make it as widely and
is easily available as sexual liberators
wanted sex to be in the meantime we
should strive to make ourselves as much
at peace as we can with the idea of
being alone for a very long time only
then do we stand a chance of deciding to
be with someone on the basis of their
own and true
it's
you